all right it is trending this morning a
couple on their way here to las vegas
well they ended up getting married
thousands of feet up in the air on board
a southwest airlines flight so this is
pam and jeremy they flew from oklahoma
city to dallas fort worth and then they
were supposed to come here but
apparently their connecting flight had
been canceled two lovebirds were kind of
chatting it up and another guy on his
way to las vegas chris overheard them
talking about how they would likely miss
their wedding
appointment happening here in las vegas
so well chris he apparently was an
ordained minister and he said you know
what i'll do this for you on the next
flight
jeremy you may kiss your bride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can see the toilet paper there as
decoration from the flight attendants uh
by the way chris the minister he works
in broadcasting so the couple had a
professional video taken and
you know it's las vegas there happen to
also be another professional
photographer who was on board and then
someone with a notebook so they got to
pass it around and write you know little
love notes to the couple and
yeah that's it you know here's my
thought well i'm wondering if this is
going to be a new trend instead of
getting married in las vegas you get
married in the flight and then you can
devote your time in las vegas to the
honeymoon
it's just a way to maximize your time
and save some money because say just get
up and get married on the plane yeah
that's true you're just giving the
guests snack packs i was going to say
the reception is little peanuts and
crackers there you go and
a shot or two maybe yeah because they
serve liquor again okay